- It's time for Drew's news,
(audience clapping)
the only news that wonders
how you've been all summer.
And with me at the desk this season,
the co-pilot of my news
dreams, Rossi, Ross Mathews.
- Drew, we're back!
(audience clapping)
I have missed you so much
and what a way to kick
off season two, Drew.
- I mean, I was a girl alone in a box,
until you came and rescued me Rossi.
- Oh, I was your knight in shining armor?
- You are my knight in shining armor.
- More like knight in sequins,
but I'll take it, thank you Drew.
- True, true, true.
All right, we're going to jump right in
with this epic movie news.
Apparently everyone in
Hollywood is starring in,
"Don't Look Up" and it's
the new movie by Adam McKay.
Adam McKay has done everything, "Vice"...
- "Anchorman"...
- Yeah.
- "Big Short".
- Yes, he's a genius.
- Uh-huh.
- The trailer's out now
and Variety reports,
that Leonardo DiCaprio is so hot.
And Jennifer Lawrence also,
so hot.
- [Ross] So hot!
- Star as two astronomers,
trying to save the world
from total destruction.
It's a reality movie...
(Ross laughing)
Thank God, just kidding,
it's not, it's fictional, take a look.
(dramatic music)
- There's a comet headed
directly towards earth.
Do you know how many, "The
world is ending", meetings
we've had over the last two years?
- Drought, famine, oh, and
the ozone is so boring.
- I mean, Meryl Streep is
the fricking president.
(audience clapping)
- [Ross] Yes!
- [Ross] Meryl Streep, you got
my vote, thank you so much.
- [Drew] I want her to be
the president for real.
- I know!
Secretary of State, Diane
Keaton, I'll take it.
- Absolutely, Diane,
please come on this show.
We are, I mean...please.
(audience clapping)
We stalk her, we stand,
Diane Keaton, I mean, hello.
- Hello!
You look like the Annie
Hall of fame, right now.
- Ms. Diane Keaton, please,
take my hand in fashion-marriage
and please grace us with your presence.
God, we love her so much, and guess what?
- [Ross] What?
- We have more good news, Ross.
- Oh yeah, so Jennifer
Lawrence, did you hear this?
"People" reports, she's
got a bun in the oven
and it's not sourdough.
She is expecting her first
child with her husband,
art gallery director, Cooke Maroney.
(audience clapping)
I love her so much.
And do you know what you call it
when a pregnant Jennifer
Lawrence has cravings?
Hunger games. (laughing)
- You know...
- What?
No, don't clap.
- I actually have a story
about Jennifer Laurence...
- [Ross] Tell me everything!
- Okay, I was at lunch with
her, me, and Cameron Diaz.
So we're in the restaurant
and we see this guy outside
and he looks like a paparazzi,
and he's on a moped, and he's got cameras.
And we're like, oh, we're
all in the restaurant,
and we, you know, we just
showed up looking crappy
and we're all just like,
oh God, it's that moment.
And we're like, you know
what, let's just go out.
And he was a nature photographer,
had no interest in us
and boy, did we feel stupid.
- Oh, that's hilarious!
- And it was hilarious,
and we all just had a big
laugh at our own expense.
- Oh, I love that.
(audience clapping)
- We were like, oh, he doesn't care at all
about the three of us,
he is a birdwatcher.
- I know, but he missed
like the best picture ever,
can you imagine?
Wow.
- Okay, I'm very
interested to get your take
on this next story, Rossi.
- Hit it.
- Because a new study from the
American Institute of Physics
found that heterosexual women
consistently rated men,
who speak less clearly,
are more attractive.
- [Ross] What?
- What?
- The mumbling got these
lady's motors a rumbling.
And now previous science
found that straight men,
on the other hand, were
more attracted to women
who clearly speak and annunciate.
You heard me.
- I heard you.
- We're going to get Tanya's take,
who is right here, in the audience.
And you say, that you love
a mumbling man, Tanya?
- Yes, I do actually.
And he's sitting next to me.
- Oh, no!
(audience clapping)
- Hi.
(Tanya laughing)
- So, okay, what was the draw,
other than the mumbling?
- He was trying to ask
me out, he was mumbling
and I found it very cute and attractive.
I felt like he was kind of shy
and some sensitive side
in him, for some reason.
Three years later, he
asked me to marry him.
He proposed and he mumbled again.
(audience laughing)
- Can you do an impression,
how did he do it?
- Well, he couldn't say it,
but he wrote it down in a little note,
and he gave me some roses,
and he had the ring.
And then he was like,
would you marry me baby?
That's what it said on the note.
And I clearly understood,
that's what he was asking.
- Gus, why do you think that
you just are so darn charming?
- (laughing) Well, first of all,
like I was really nervous,
because she's so beautiful
and you know, I just got,
I just started a mumbling
and I couldn't get it right.
And so when I wanted
to ask her to marry me,
I was like, I'm going to mumble again.
And so I wrote it down just in case,
so that she can get the message.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you, Tanya and
Gus, this was so fun.
It's our first official news in Hollywood.
- I know and we've got an
audience, thank you guys!
- We love you guys!
(upbeat music)